.
>> SWIPE RIGHT.
GOING ALL IN ON A DATING APP
DESIGNED FOR CONSERVATIVES.
>> EVERYTHING IS FAIR IN LOVE
AND POLITICS.
FIRST, MORE BUSLOADS OF MIGRANTS
ARRIVING IN SANCTUARY CITIES
CAUSING QUITE THE MELTDOWN AMONG
DEMOCRATS.
TODAY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WERE
DROPPED OFF OUTSIDE VICE
PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS' HOME IN
WASHINGTON D.C.
AN INTERVIEW WITH VICE NEWS
HARRIS LAND TEXAS GOVERNOR
ABBOTT AND FLORIDA GOVERNOR
DESANTIS SAYING I THINK IT'S THE
HEIGHT OF IRRESPONSIBILITY MUCH
LESS JUST FRANKLY DERELICTION OF
DUTY.
MEANTIME MIGRANTS ARE POURING
OVER THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
FOX NEWS DRONE TEAM CAPTURING
HUNDREDS OF THEM CROSSING
ILLEGALLY, INCREDIBLE VIDEO.
THE NUMBER OF MIGRANTS SENT TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD, .0025 ON THE
TOTAL ENCOUNTERS OF THE BORDER
THIS YEAR.
MARTHA'S VINEYARD QUICKLY
SHIPPED THEM OUT TO CAPE COD.
>> INSTEAD OF SCRAMBLING
WORRYING ABOUT RICH PEOPLE AND
HAVING 50 AND BY THE WAY, THEY
BUST THEM OUT, THEY ARE GONE.
THEY SAID WE WANT EVERYONE, NO
WAS ILLEGAL AND THEY ARE GONE
WITHIN 48 HOURS.
>> LET'S TAKE IT TO THE PANEL,
LET'S LAY OUT THE FACTS FIRST.
FIFTY IMMIGRANTS, ILLEGAL RENTS
WERE CRITICALLY ASYLUM-SEEKERS
ARRIVED IN MARTHA'S VINEYARD
QUICKLY TAKEN TO AN AIR FORCE
BASE, MILITARY BASE IN CAPE COD
BECAUSE I GUESS THE ISLAND
COULDN'T SUPPORT THE IMMIGRANTS,
THEY DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH HOUSING
BUT LET'S BE HONEST, IT'S AN
ISLAND WITH A PLETHORA OF
HOTELS, MOTELS, AIR B&BS, PLENTY
OF ROOMS TO PLAY DURING THE YEAR
17000 PEOPLE LIVE ON THE ISLAND
IN THE SUMMER, THAT NUMBER
SWELLS TO 200,000.
I THINK THERE WERE PLACES REALLY
WOULD HAVE STAYED.
I LIKE TO PUT UP RIGHT NOW A
LIST OF DATES THAT CALL
THEMSELVES IN SANCTUARY.
THERE TAKE A LOOK.
YOU SEE CALIFORNIA, COLORADO,
CONNECTICUT, ILLINOIS AND
MASSACHUSETTS, MASSACHUSETTS
CONSIDERS ITSELF SAME TRI-STATE,
MARTHA'S VINEYARD IS IN
MASSACHUSETTS JASON, I KNOW THIS
SOUNDS A LITTLE SARCASTIC BUT
SHOULD THEY HAVE TAKEN THE
MIGRANTS AND PUT THEM UP
SOMEWHERE RATHER THAN SEND THEM
OFF IN JUST A DAY OR TWO?
>> THIS SHOULD NEVER HAVE BEEN
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THE BIDEN HARRIS ADMINISTRATION
MADE A CONSCIOUS EFFORT TO BRING
PEOPLE AND ATTRACT THEM WITH
THIS MIGRANT THE SAYS WE WILL
RELEASE YOU INTO THE UNITED
STATES AMERICA IN BIG STATES
LIKE TEXAS AND ARIZONA,
CALIFORNIA, NEW MEXICO BUT BY
THE MILLIONS.
A FEW DOZEN SHOW UP AT MARTHA'S
VINEYARD AND OF MY GOODNESS,
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH AIR B&BS TO
HANDLE THIS.
GOVERNOR DESANTIS IS DOING, WHAT
GOVERNOR DOOCY IS DOING IS RIGHT
TO SHARE A FEW, I USED TO BE
ONLY IMMIGRATION SUBCOMMITTEE IN
CONGRESS.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW THE WHITE
HOUSE IS TRYING TO BLAME
REPUBLICAN OBSTRUCTIONISM AND I
LAUGH AT THAT.
WHERE'S THE DEMOCRATIC BILL IF
THEY ARE SO ADAMANT ABOUT IT?
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE THE HOUSE AND
SET IT IF THEY THINK REPUBLICANS
BECAUSE THIS, IT'S ONLY BIDEN
AND HARRIS CAUSING THIS.
>> I GUESS OF THE END OF THE DAY
IT'S UP TO CONGRESS TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
>> THE PRESIDENT COULD LOCKDOWN
THE BORDER, THE LAWS ON THE
BOOK, THERE'S NOTHING ON THERE
THAT SAYS YOU HAVE TO LET THEM
IN.
LEGALLY AND LAWFULLY WE BRING IN
ABOUT 1 MILLION PEOPLE A YEAR.
IT'S ONLY HUNTER BIDEN AND
HARRIS THEY CHANGED SOMETHING
LIKE 90 DIFFERENT RULES, THEY
ARE DOING CATCH AND RELEASE, THE
WHITE HOUSE WON'T EVEN SPEAK
WITH BORDER PATROL.
ASK A BORDER PATROL AGENT WHAT
WE SHOULD DO, THEY ARE ON THE
FRONT LINE AND WE SHOULD BE
ASKING THEM.
>> THEY ARE IN A LOT OF OVERTIME
FOR SURE.
IN THIS CASE WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT 50 PEOPLE BUT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE BORDER, TOWNS LIKE
EL PASO EAGLE PASS, DEL RIO,
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ARE POURING
IN.
TALK ABOUT THE IMPACT HEALTHWISE
ON THESE CITIES, THESE PEOPLE
HAVE TO BE SCREENED, THEY MADE A
LONG TRUST ABOUT THE BORDER,
THEY NEED MEDICAL CARE, HOW DOES
IT IMPACT THE HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE CITY?
>> I THINK GOVERNOR DESANTIS WAS
JUST TRYING TO MAKE POINTS THE
RESOURCES REQUIRED TO CARE FOR
THEM COMING ACROSS THE BORDER IN
DROVES AND 50 WERE SENT TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD, 300 TO 500
EVERYDAY COME IN TWO EAGLE PASS,
TEXAS, A SMALL TOWN, THE AVERAGE
INCOME OF A HOUSEHOLD IS ABOUT
$40000.
YOU THINK THEY HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THIS AMOUNT
OF PEOPLE?
OF COURSE NOT.
RON DESANTIS MADE POINTS, YOU
ALREADY QUOTED THE NUMBERS, I
HAD IT WRITTEN DOWN, MARTHA'S
VINEYARD, 17000 RESIDENTS LIVE
THERE ALL THE TIME.
IN THE SUMMER, SOMEHOW THEY ARE
ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF 200,000
PEOPLE.
THERE ARE ANTI- HOMES, IF
ANYBODY CAN HANDLE A FEW MORE
PEOPLE, I WOULD THINK IT WOULD
BE MARTHA'S VINEYARD BUT YOU ARE
RIGHT, HEALTH SCREENINGS AND
PEOPLE REQUIRING MEDICAL CARE,
YOU NEED THE CHILDREN IN SCHOOLS
IN A SAFE ENVIRONMENT AND THIS
TAKES A LOT OF RESOURCES AND
IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK JUST BY
SHIPPING THEM OUT.
IT'S ALSO NOT GOING TO WORK
KEEPING WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW, STATUS QUO, WE HAVE TO STOP
THEM FROM COMING TO THE COUNTRY
AND IT NEEDS TO HAPPEN IN AN
ORDERLY PROCESS BECAUSE
IMPORTANTLY YOU WILL HAVE THESE
PEOPLE SUFFERING IF THEY COME IN
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO TAKE CARE OF THEM
BUT ONE QUICK THING, WE HAD
KAMALA HARRIS EARLIER WHERE YOU
SAID SHE WAS ESSENTIALLY
INCOMING WAS GOING ON LET'S
THINK OF THIS, CNN RECENTLY SAID
DESANTIS APPROVAL RATINGS OVER
50%, TEXAS POLITICS NEWEST POLL
CAME OUT SHOWING ABBOTT IS ABOUT
36% APPROVAL RATING YET NEW YORK
TIMES SAYS HARRIS, THE BORDER
CZAR HAS ABOUT 39% APPROVAL
RATING SO SOMETHING TELLS ME
AMERICANS SEE IMMIGRATION IS AN
ISSUE AND OBVIOUSLY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT HANDLING
IT RECTALLY.
>> AMERICANS DEFINITELY THINK
IT'S AN ISSUE AND THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE CRITICAL ABOUT
GOVERNOR DESANTIS FOR PULLING
THIS WHAT THEY CALL A STUNNED
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR FROM
MIGRANTS, AT LEAST ONE MAN WHO
SAID THIS WAS ONE OF THE BEST
THINGS THAT HAS EVER HAPPENED TO
HIM.
[SPEAKING IN SPANISH]
>> HE DIDN'T SEE TO UPSET BEING
SHIPPED TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
I WANT TO LISTEN TO MOST OF THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA VIEWED THIS
EVENT.
>> THERE'S GREG ABBOTT AND DOUG
DUCEY, WE HATE IMMIGRANTS, GET
THE F OUT AND WE WILL HELP YOU
GET OUT.
>> THIS TACTIC BY SUPPOSEDLY
CHRISTIAN RIGHT POLITICS, ABOUT
AS UNCHRISTIAN AS IT GETS.
>> IT'S SO CRUEL AND UNNECESSARY
AND UNCOMFORTABLE AND BRAZEN, IT
SHOCKS THE CONSCIENCE OF ANY
HUMAN BEING.
>> SOME POLITICIANS WOULD RATHER
NOT ONLY HAVE AN ISSUE BUT
EXACERBATED TO THE EXTENT OF
LITERALLY HUMAN TRAFFICKING AS
YOU SAID.
>> TYRUS, I'D LIKE YOUR
THOUGHTS.
>> IT IS OFF SEASON, A TOUGH
TIME TO GO.
I'M SURE THE BEACHES WERE CLEAN
BUT THE REPUBLICANS DIDN'T START
THIS SHIPPING PARTY, HE WAS NOT
THE FIRST ONE, ABBOTT WAS NOT
THE FIRST ONE.
WHO WAS THAT GUY?
OH YEAH, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION FLYING PEOPLE ON
RED EYES WHICH I COULD NEVER GET
TO GO HOME TO NORTH CAROLINA AND
FLORIDA FLYING THEM OUT AT NIGHT
SO I GUESS IF YOU DO IT AT NIGHT
IT'S BETTER BUT THIS IS FIRST
WORLD PROBLEMS AND INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE AFFECTED IN THE FIRST
THING THEY DO IS IT'S NOT THERE
TO BRING THEM HERE.
WHERE SHOULD WE BRING THEM?
YOU TALK ABOUT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, IT'S NOT MARTHA'S
VINEYARD, IT'S THE BORDER SO THE
ONES NOT SEEKING ACROSS GETTING
THESE TRIPS ARE GOING TO THE
CARTEL STRAP WITH MENTAL OR
WORSE IF THEY ARE YOUNG, 30%
YOUNG WOMEN TRYING TO CROSS IF
THEY ARE NOT GANG RAPED OR SOLD
INTO THE SEX SLAVE INDUSTRY,
THOSE ARE REAL PROBLEMS, NOT I
STEPPED OUTSIDE TO HAVE MY CUP
OF FRESH COFFEE AND TALK 50
PEOPLE WITH SMILES ON THEIR FACE
TAKING SELFIES WITH THEIR NEW
CELL PHONES GIVEN BY THE UNITED
STATES, THAT'S NOT A KIDNAP
VICTIM.
>> THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING STARTS
WHEN THE CONTRACT WITH THE DRUG
CARTEL.
THEY PAY THEM THOUSANDS TO THE
COYOTES TO COME NORTH AND BRING
THEM ACROSS THE BORDER THEY WANT
TO GET CAUGHT BECA